[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale du moment tout de
suite les titres de ce mercredi 16
janvier une cérémonie commune au
vélodrome nationale yvelines et
hauts-de-seine ont présenté leurs voeux
hier les deux collectivités souhaitent
continuer leur processus de fusion
entamé en 2016 pas de grandes annonces
pendant la soirée mais des discours
offensifs contre l'action du
gouvernement
ambiance studieuse ce matin à elancourt
le comité restreint de la gsm
association des enseignants de
maternelle se réunissaient pendant trois
jours ses membres vont travailler sur le
programme du prochain congrès national
dans l'académie de versailles c'est en
juillet à port marly et vous l'avez
sûrement vu aujourd'hui le soleil a fait
un court retour après plusieurs jours
d'absence pas de quoi remonter pour
autant le moral des yvelinois cette
grisaille exceptionnel en ce début
d'année
va-t-elle continuer éléments de réponse
et puis deux invités avec moi sur ce
plateau dans un instant joséphine
coleman berger maire de plaisir et puis
un autre maire celui de saint cyr
l'école bernard dedans on début de cette
édition par de la politique et les voeux
des départements yvelinois et
alto-séquanais une cérémonie commune des
présidents qui souhaite toujours réussir
à obtenir le feu vert de l'état dans
leur projet de fusion nicolas d'andré
wilfried riches y était ce mardi soir au
vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux où se tenait la soirée les
deux présidents les républicains des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine réunis au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en ce début
d'année une cérémonie de voeux en commun
pour des discours très politique dans la
ligne de mire de pierre bédier et
patrick devedjan le gouvernement et son
grand débat national
ces débats je le crains nous nous
réjouirons que les chaînes d'information
continue et les plus extrêmes trouveront
de toute façon à mettre en scène les
mécontentements du peuple et les deux
présidents de demander plus de liberté
pour la nouvelle année liberté notamment
de poursuivre le rapprochement de leur
département afin d'obtenir la validation
du projet de fusion nous avons rempli
toutes les obligations
égale qui permettent la fusion donc le
gouvernement est mal venu de considérer
ou de déclarer qu'il y a trop de
collectivités locales que ceux-ci
génèrent des coûts nous nous proposons
au contraire de fusionner et nous avons
répondu à toutes les obligations légales
pour ça et le gouvernement fait la
sourde oreille
je veux dire à l'état qu'il n'a pas le
monopole de l'intérêt général que nous
partageons l'état et les collectivités
ce souci de l'intérêt général et qu'il
faut sortir de ce système très archaïque
d'un état centralisateur neta qui décide
de tout parce qu'en l'état décide de
tout rien ne marche
un seul mot d'ordre donc au cours de
cette soirée décentralisation pad
annonce de nouveaux projets en revanche
pour le moment yvelines et
hauts-de-seine partage notamment un
service de voirie ou encore
d'archéologie et d'adoption sur ce
plateau deux invités de maires de
communes des yvelines oise joséphine
coleman ce berger bonsoir voir sa mère
de à plaisir et bonsoir bernard de bain
bonsoir avec le maire de saint cyr
l'école avant de parler avec vous deux
sujets qui concernent vos villes une
réaction peut-être sur une actualité
nationale le grand débat national
justement qui a été lancé officiellement
hier par le président de la république
jusqu'au 15 mars une grande réflexion
avec les citoyens pour sortir de cette
crise des gilet jaune est ce que vous en
attendez beaucoup jeux des films comme
anne berger
on espère je suis un peu perplexe
malgré tout parce que on voit bien les
demandes aujourd'hui qu'il s'en fait et
qui sont un petit peu tous azimuts en
jeu je me permets de mettre cette
expression à l'heure du jour parce que
c'est bien ce qu'on ressent malgré tout
alors c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
que l'on a demandé vous savez qu'on est
allé avec autour de monsieur karl olive
rencontré le président émotions général
phung ferrand exactement et on l'avait
rencontré et suite à ça on lui avait
bien dit que l'appui des maires étaient
indispensables pour avoir en tout cas un
retour de la population donc on va
mettre en place et on a mis en place en
ce qui me concerne sur la ville de
plaisir
cette concertation qu'est ce qu'on en
attend je vous dirais que et bien en
tout cas la preuve le fait que les gens
puissent exprimer déjà c'est une chose
importante c'est attendu c'est
souhaitait donc ils peuvent s'exprimer
la facilité aussi cette concertation par
l'organisation peut-être de réunion
plusieurs oui en même temps je crois que
les mères on le faisait tous déjà vous
savez les concertations dans oz et dans
les quartiers on entend un peu partout
on évoquer les sujets bien sûr de la
ville mais on évoqué très souvent aussi
les problèmes nationaux donc c'est
quelque chose que l'on sait et
d'ailleurs quand on est allé voir le
président on lui a fait remonter déjà
des informations qui sont des
informations des quatre questions qui
ont été posées par le président donc
quelque part oui pourquoi pas en
attendre quelque chose mais je suis un
peu perplexe il bernard devant votre
sentiment sur ce grand débat national
faire un débat national ça me pose un
petit problème en terme de
représentation
il ya des élus au niveau local comme les
mains il ya aussi la majorité
présidentielle si on ne prend qu elle
qui est kid ory théoriquement devrait
faire remonter remonter à au ministre et
au président les questions que se posent
administrés de l'occire conscription ça
prouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
marche pas en tous les cas tels que ça
se passe alors actuelle et refaire un
grand débat national
j'ai bien peur que ça soit un peu touffu
un peu confus je suis pas sûr que ça ne
soit pas un peu de la poudre aux yeux
s'il en sort quelque chose et que ça
peut calmer et faire se terminer la
crise des gilets jaunes qui par endroits
coûte cher à l'économie locale
parce que
le blocage ça peut coûter cher à
l'économie locale
et puis redonner une meilleure idée de
la france vis-à-vis des touristes
étrangers
ce serait formidable ça sera donc à
suivre dans leur demain je poursuis
l'entretien avec vous sur les sujets
plus locaux sur saint cyr l'école déjà
rassurés nous plus de danger une bombe
de 250 kilos datant de la seconde guerre
mondiale a été découverte hier sur un
chantier un périmètre de sécurité avait
été établi à tout est revenu à la
normale l'engin était désamorcé l'engin
a été désamorcé je dois dire que nous
avons en france des équipes de services
de déminage et dieu sait si à saint cyr
y sont habitués mais un peu partout
parce que on a quand même été le chant
de deux grandes guerres mondiales mais
je vous rassure tout de suite c'était
c'était pas une saint cyrienne c'était
une vieille anglaise née anglaise qui
habitait versailles
certes à 40 mètres de saint cyr mais
l'habileté versailles en tout cas tout
est est revenue à la normale or vous
profitez de ce mois de janvier pour bien
sûr présenter vos voeux aux différents
quartiers de la ville vendredi c'était
pour les habitants du quartier de
l'abbaye et de l'hôtel de ville
alors vous avez confirmé une annonce que
qui était déjà faite celle que vous ne
serez pas candidat a pour un nouveau
mandat en 2020
ce n'est pas une surprise ça sera vous
étés pardon vous avez vous étiez maire
depuis 2006 est ce que vous estimez
avoir fait votre temps bernard de ben je
sais pas si on a fait son temps vous
savez quand on est maire je crois que si
on est maire c'est parce qu'on le fait
que passion parce que être mère j'ai
toujours considéré que c'était être au
service des eaux rude donc être au
service des autres il ya toujours
quelque chose à faire mais j'avais dit
lorsque j'avais delluc jeu près de mamba
est bien
les demandes a théoriquement son fini
puisque théoriquement demande à ses 12
ans mais on nous en a rajouté un avec à
des galas de l'élection de 2007
mais je ne me représenterai pas j'ai
l'âge de prendre une retraite comme on
dit heureuse en pleine forme avec une
épouse qui n'attend que ça et je crois
que la meilleure des choses c'est de
pouvoir transmettre le témoin il y aura
toujours quelque chose à faire
alors d'içi là d'ici la fin de ce mandat
en 2020 il reste un peu plus d'un an
il ya bien sûr des grands dossiers en
2019 qui vont se concrétiser pour la
ville de saint cyr un chantier déjà qui
va être lancée celui du tram-train 13
qui reliera à saint cyr à saint germain
en laye en 30 minutes le chantier a pris
la livraison de ce chantier prévu en
2021 c'est quelque chose qui est très
attendu par les saint cyriens se trament
13 bat d'autant plus attendu que
quelques années de retard 10 ans rapport
ce qui avait été annoncé en 2008 puisque
on nous avait promis 2012 mais bon ne
faisons pas la fine bouche on y est
arrivé et je dois ans l'a remerciée
valérie pécresse qui a largement sauvé
dossier parce que il ya beaucoup
d'argent en jeu plus de 330 millions
d'euros et que à l'heure où il faut
faire des économies
il ya un certain nombre de projets qui
ont été largement décalé dans le temps
comme les lignes 18 par exemple et que
le fait d'avoir sauvé ce tram-train qui
est une liaison qui ne va pas vers paris
c'est vraiment banlieue banlieue et
c'est ce qui nous manque grandement que
la violence donc c'est vraiment très
attendu par tous les usagers de cette
ligne donc chez germain d'abord lui est
cher et un jour cergy naturellement
d'autres réalisations va finir avec ça
un pôle sportif et une maison des
associations c'est aussi des équipements
qui était attendu par vos habitants
nécessaire attendu et nécessaire
il ya beaucoup d'associations sportives
on manque on avait deux gymnases on aura
l'équivalent de 4 avec des sports
nouveau puisqu'on pourra faire l'escala
de faire de l'escrim choses qu'on ne
faisait pas ça si et d'autres qui auront
un peu plus d espace plus de confort
puisque en plus on aura un gymnase de
dimension régionale ce qui permettra
d'organiser belle compétition
quant à la maison des associations nous
montrons de place beaucoup
d'associations soit partagée des locaux
soit carrément n'en avait pas et là en
plus ils pourront se rencontrer parce
qu'ils seront tous ensemble dans un très
très beau bâtiment
merci mais bernard de bernardin pour
pour toutes ces précisions joséphine
coleman berger c'est à vous je rappelle
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent que vous êtes la mère de
plaisir la ville qui a pour objectif
cette année ce sera le premier sujet
pour cette année ou en 2020 en tout cas
de créer un garage solidaire il verrait
le jour dans le quartier du val hibou
une parcelle a été acheté pour le
réaliser faisons deux camps sur sur ce
projet déjà expliquez nous ce qui est un
garage solidaire alors un garage
solidaire c'est un garage que des
personnes peuvent partager non seulement
pour faire réparer leur voiture mais
également pour avoir
pourquoi pas des emplois d'insertion
d'apprentissage est également avoir une
tarification
je dirais de réparation les pions toute
concurrence mais ce qui est surtout
important c'est d'insérer ce projet dans
le quartier du val hibou et la
réhabilitation du vél bout puisque tout
semblait ce projet bien sûr
loto voyez comme quoi le temps passe je
rejoins mon collègue
les années passent et on est pourtant
toujours sur sur les sujets et c'est
vrai que ce quartier qui est en
réhabilitation est également dans l'anru
aujourd'hui nous attendons d'ailleurs la
décision de l'état par rapport à
l'accompagnement et le garage solidaire
est un des éléments de ce quartier qui
doit muter complètement dans une
transformation tant au niveau du des
écoles que justement des associations
également d'équipements du centre
commercial qui doit être fait et le
garage solidaire
la ville vient d'acquérir vous l'avez
dit ce terrain qui va nous permettre de
le faire assez rapidement puisque nous
avons beau
beaucoup de deux je dirais de mécanique
sauvage sur les quartiers qui crée des
situations assez compliqué donc j'espère
que ça va répondre aux attentes des
habitants
on voit ce genre de projet émerger en
france mais c'est plus à l'initiative de
particuliers là c'est un projet
municipal c'est important de le lancer
pour le oui c'était fondamental puisque
c'est dans un équilibre du quartier mais
également je dirais attendu par les
habitants puis on a des exemples qui se
sont très bien passées qui se passe bien
sûr d'autres villes comme à trappes
ailleurs en a pris des contacts pour
travailler un petit peu dans la même
dynamique et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui va résoudre des soucis des
problèmes vous parler davantage
notamment réduire cette mécanique
sauvage on imagine aussi faire réparer
sa voiture à moindre coût il y aussi un
impact écologique qui va être réduit
grâce à ce virage
jusqu'aujourd'hui vous savez que la
mécanique sauvage et bien ça donne des
résultats assez compliquée avec des
huiles qui peuvent entrer aussi dans les
sous-sols donc tout ça c'est très
compliqué donc il ya le côté écologique
et le côté insertion qui n'est pas à
négliger puisque ça va peut nous
permettre peut-être d'accompagner des
jeunes sur des formations pour aller au
delà
bien sûr du garage solidaire par la
suite vous disais ça va aller très vite
où on est le projet aujourd'hui ou telle
acquisition du terrain était fait on est
en contact avec des entreprises une
entreprise en tout cas qui s'occupe de
ça sur trappe
on espère je dirais que sur l'année
prochaine on puisse déjà bien avancé le
projet vous avez présenté vos voeux aux
plaisirs roi la semaine dernière
l'occasion bien sûr de faire le point
sur cette année 2010 neuf avec de grands
projets et cette année vous allez
engager une révision de votre plan local
d'urbanisme pourquoi et quelles seront
ces modifications pour écouter pourquoi
parce que déjà on a un projet qui est
autour du centre hospitalier de plaisir
puisque les deux hôpitaux que nous
avions sur plaisir ont fusionné et donc
il ya tout un espace en centre ville qui
est en train de se libérer plus de 20
hectares et donc il est plus que
fondamental d'avoir une protection par
rapport à ce foncier et une réflexion en
accord avec les habitants bien sûr de ce
que l'on veut faire de ce centre bourg
une étude a été faite aussi sur
l'ensemble du centre bourg et historique
pour voir cette mutation dans les dix
quinze années qui viennent se payait lui
va nous permettre également de respecter
ce que qui
quelque chose auquel nous tenons
beaucoup les élus mais également les
habitants de plaisir c'est l' équilibre
rural urbain puisque nous avons 54 % de
ruralité sur la ville de plaisir et on
souhaite non seulement la maintenir mais
l'a développée donc c'est un double
enjeu un enjeu de protection est un
enjeu également le développement de la
ville parce qu'il faut aussi que la
ville se développe mais avec
intelligence
un autre projet d'envergure qui va voir
le jour en fin d'année c'est la fin de
ce chantier du centre commercial open
sky et vous avait été fixé pendant les
vacances de noël plaisir aura bien son
cinéma un recours contre l'ouverture de
ce multiplexe au sein de ce centre
commercial avait été déposé par
cinémovida dont un projet similaire va
sortir de terre à maurepas ce recours a
finalement été rejetée c'est un
soulagement pour vous il faut ce cinéma
pour pour la ville mais oui il faut ce
cinéma d'abord parce qu'on en avait 1
précédemment
on avait déjà obtenu une cdac ya de
nombreuses années
ensuite les choses ont pris du temps
comme le disait bernard tout prend du
temps mais les plaisirs wa attendait
bien sûr ce cinéma on a une chalandise
dont seulement sur la ville de plaisir
mais également sur les environs et puis
au projet d'open sky et d'un projet qui
permettait justement de faire rentrer
neuf salles de cinéma donc aujourd'hui
c'est vrai nous l'avons obtenue on en
est ravie enchanté site était vraiment
un drame si on n'avait pas pu obtenir
c'est celle de cinéma là au dernier en
dernier moment puisque l'inauguration
aura lieu je pense au mois de novembre
il nous reste un peu plus d'une minute
pour évoquer ce dernier sujet vous
comptez engagé en 2019 une réflexion sur
les transports à plaisir les plaisirs
one ne sont pas satisfaits de l'offre
actuelle exactement les plaisirs war ne
sont pas du tout contents du réseau
qualité mis en place récemment par saint
quentin en yvelines où je siège donc je
prends les responsabilités et il est
vrai qu'il ya des choses qui ont été
améliorées sur des amplitudes horaires
et sur d
des lignes mais certaines lignes ont eu
des déperditions véritablement donc je
les dis lors de mes oeufs devant les
personnes concernées qui étaient
présentes pour dire que je ne lâcherai
pas la faire et que je ferai tout pour
que les plaisirs war retrouve ce confort
qu'ils avaient précédemment et qui
aujourd'hui est bien leur fait défaut
merci joséphine clottemans berger d'être
passé sur ce plateau merde plaisir et
merci également à bernard dedans pour
ses réponses rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de saint cyr l'école on parlait
justement tout à l'heure du grand débat
national et du rôle des élus l'anif
l'association des maires d'île de france
a transmis 2000 doléances au préfet de
région à des contributions collectées
par des mairies à volontaires ou
enregistrées via un outil de sondage en
ligne
la participation a été forte surtout du
côté de la seine et marne de l'essonne
et des yvelines et les retours se
concentre principalement sur l'impôt sur
la fortune ou encore sur la hausse du
smic une prime de 300 euros pour les
agents des lycées franciliens elle sera
versée en mars à 8500 personnes annonce
hier de la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse compensation ont donné
suite aux violences qui ont touché
certains établissements en marge des
manifestations contre la réforme du
lycée
en tout les dégâts se chiffrent à 1
million et demi d'euros sur l'ensemble
du territoire francilien
aujourd'hui débutait trois jours de
réunion pour l'organisation d'un congrès
annuel celui de l'âge et em
l'association générale des enseignants
des écoles et classes maternelles
publiques ce congrès est programmée à
partir du 3 juillet à port marly mais le
travail en amont a déjà commencé manon
varaldo s'est rendu aux médias paule le
d'elancourt pour la première journée de
préparatifs le port marly sera la ville
où se tiendra le 92ème congrès national
de la gm
l'association générale des enseignants
des écoles et classes maternelles
publiques
elle a été créée en 1921 elle a été
créée à vichy par un groupe
d'enseignants tu vois là dès qu'ils se
sont réunis parce qu'il y avait déjà une
inégalité de salaires
à cette époque et les collègues se sont
regroupés autour de cette association
pour faire la promotion de l'école
maternelle pour défendre les intérêts
des enseignants et défendre les intérêts
des enfants
en comité restreint tous réfléchissent à
l'organisation du congrès annuel pour
promouvoir l'école maternelle et en
particulier la thématique des arts c'est
un véritable moment où bat le coeur de
la maternelle et où les enseignants qui
viennent là c'est en même temps pour se
ressourcer pour partager et au sein de
l'académie de versailles
tous ceux qui ont travaillé depuis
depuis trois ans et offrir ce moment et
ses espaces pour se retrouver et parler
de la maternelle qui est nôtre voilà
notre passion il met au point
l'organisation des expositions
pédagogiques mais aussi toute la
logistique
pendant trois jours ils établissent le
programme précis des journées du congrès
en rendez vous très attendu pour les
enseignantes passionnant de pouvoir
rencontrer ce qui est fait par les
autres collègues échanger avec les
autres collectes sur ce qu'elles font
leurs pratiques de classe et cet échange
là est source de formation pour nous
mille deux cents personnes sont
attendues au congrès il se déroulera du
3 au 5 juillet 2019 aux pyramides à
port-marly un préavis avait été déposé
pour les journées d'aujourd'hui de
demain et de vendredi finalement pas de
grève à l'enppi à l'hôpital andré mignot
du chesnay rocancourt est les
représentants syndicaux se dit satisfait
de l'avancée des négociations avec la
direction hier mardi une quarantaine
d'infirmiers anesthésistes et
chirurgiens avaient débrayé pendant une
heure il dénonce de mauvaises conditions
de travail
un manque d'effectifs et une maternité
surchargé on n'avait pas vu quasiment
depuis le passage à 2019 le soleil a
fait une courte apparition ce matin dans
les yvelines un début d'année
exceptionnellement grille avec moins de
quatre heures d'ensoleillement
jusqu'à hier du jamais vu depuis 1972
alors comment la situation va-t-elle
évoluer qu'en pensez vous reportage de
manon varaldo et de michael et demi
d'euros depuis le 1er janvier les ivy
mois peuvent dissocier plus de 50 nuance
de gris dans le ciel aux quatre coins du
département
le soleil est porté disparu suite à une
perturbation venue des îles britanniques
et cela joue évidemment sur leur moral
dépassés les tropiques et oui oui c'est
une déprime cc on est on est à la fin là
franchement on touche le bout bon je me
sens bien avoir mesuré mais c'est pas
méchant loup gris non plus la preuve du
gris au total les yvelinois n'ont vu le
soleil que 3h58 au 14 janvier d'après un
relevé de la station météorologique de
trappes un phénomène rarissime qu'on en
perd quand même
pr marc câble c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé était arrivé par le passé sur la
même période
en 1953 où on avait eu seulement deux
heures en 1972 on avait pu profiter
preuve heure et 48 minutes
d'entraînement vraiment les nuages
devraient prolonger leur séjour sur les
i ville dans les prochaines semaines les
températures quand elles baisseront ce
qui pourrait entraîner quelques flocons
dans le département ce week-end ou en
début de semaine prochaine
un mot de culture à présent avec une
exposition depuis le 7 janvier corinne
cska présente plusieurs de ces monotypes
à la galerie à saint-simon de versailles
et des oeuvres réalisées autour du corps
humain et du mouvement mélanie poquet
des corps humains sensuelle qui semble
poser des peintures monotype corinne
cesca travaille sur une plaque de métal
sans gravure créant des modèles inédits
des oeuvres réalisées grâce à une
vieille presse artisanale
je travaille sur les émotions
en fait ce qui est ce que mon c'est la
diversité des émotions et je passe par
le corps je cherche un langage sur le
monotype pour un langage pour exprimer
dans le corps sur les inversions de deux
hanches la puissance de l'émotion aussi
en essayant de par exemple de partir un
pied propulser la tête
corinne cesca découvre son amour pour
l'art en 2006 une pratique tardive qui
passe par un envoûtement une révélation
lestang plus permet aux possibilités
infinies de création c'est la technique
du monotype qui m'a
complètement séduit parce qu'on
travaille sur une plaque de métal on
peut enlever rajouter gradés et on peut
tout faire pour une feuille de papier
grimper par dessus j'ai le plaisir du
geste aussi quand il ya des rythmes où
on peut partir de dans le mouvement
c'est la puissance c'est le moi qu'il
faut que j'inscrive quoi fonctions ce
qu'est ce qui vous bien comme comme
émotion sur la plaque un art exutoire
pour l'artiste corinne c'est ce qu'a
exposé ces trois dernières années de
création et puis refermons ce journal au
cinéma chaque semaine nous faisons le
tour des salles obscures
saint-quentinoise direction les clés sio
les quais sous bois pardon à l'espace
philippe noiret pour connaître la
programmation de la semaine c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
votre compte un programme de courts
métrages monsieur chat et les chemises
accessible dès 2 ans parfaite pour une
première séance au cinéma que vous
pouvez trouver dans le cas de notre
saison jeune public
cette année on a décidé dans le cadre de
cette saison de proposer un abonnement
pour les familles donc la possibilité de
s'abonner et d'avoir des places de
cinéma et de théâtre un prix défiant
toute concurrence et donc cette semaine
monsieur chat et les chats mise c'est un
programme de six courts métrages qui est
original parce qu'ils mélangent
les matières donc il ya un chat un vrai
chat incrusté dans un des films
d'animation avec des tissus de la laine
des boutons et donc ses six histoires
autour du quotidien voilà dans
lesquelles les chemises jouer à
cache-cache rangent leurs chambres
prennent le bain donc c'est vraiment
très adapté pour les plus petits pour
pourquoi pas une première séance à voir
un noir et cette semaine les talons de
15 et 17 ans à salle de bain
[Musique]
boum
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition le
7-8 journal est à retrouver sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv et 78 dans un instant nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat avec pour thématique
le grand débat national
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
oh